c'est quand même si vous voulez une
énorme hypocrisie parce que on voit bien
que la dynamique actuelle des prix de
tous les carburants que ce soit le
pétrole fait que ce soit les sens que ce
soit le gard où que ce soit
l'électricité tout ça c'est de l'énergie
globalement que tous ces prix sont
aujourd'hui dominé par une dynamique qui
est la dynamique de privatisation et de
déréglementation qu'a voulu impulser
l'union européenne au nom justement de
la construction d'un grand marché unique
de l'énergie et que les gouvernements
français c'est pas que la faute à
bruxelles à il faut être honnête à dieu
que les gouvernements français se sont
précipités pour faire appliquer
le gasoil et l'essence en passe de
devenir des produits de luxe ont presque
avec cette flambée des prix qui touche
toute l'europe carburant d'un côté gaz
électricité de l'autre l'addition
commence à devenir très salée pour les
ménages on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir dans son
édito est qu
un bon soir jacques merci d'être avec
nous un pour cette actualité brûlante
avec ses annonces de jean castex ce soir
on va essayer elle vous d'approfondir de
de comprendre davantage ces mécanismes
qui font les les prix de l'énergie tout
d'abord à quoi ces hausses sont tendues
alors effectivement et ce sont des
hausses qui commence vraiment à faire
mal aux consommateurs qui commence à
faire mal et aux classes moyennes et aux
classes populaires alors c'est au cep
sont dus à quoi effectivement il y à une
hausse des cours ya même une hausse des
coûts de production mais si on regarde
un petit peu rétrospectivement on voit
que cette hausse elle est bien plus
faible que celle qu'on avait connue il
ya quelques années que ce soit en 2007
en 2013 et donc en réalité ce qu'il ya
derrière ce sont faut le dire les
incohérences de la politique du
gouvernement et de la politique
énergétique de l'union européenne qui
font que justement battre sur l'ensemble
de ce dossier il ya malheureusement
énormément d'hypocrisie de la part des
politiques elle ça veut dire que quand
les prix n'ont pas augmenté autant que
ceux là alors oui les prix ont augmenté
les cours du pétrole en particulier ont
augmenté mais effectivement vous avez
raison de dire c'est pas tant que cela
et on peut voir par exemple sur le
graphique que bah on est très en dessous
alors je ne parle même pas de ce qui
s'est passé dans la période
86 90 mais même nettement en dessous de
ce qui s'était passé de 2007 a grosso
modo 2013 aujourd'hui globalement on
serait revenu au niveau 2 2018 seulement
que c'est parce que ressentent
évidemment les ménages c'est parce que
ressent l'automobiliste qui passe à la
pompe et on voit bien que là il ya un
problème alors ce graphique ne concerne
que les prix du pétrole jacques pourquoi
alors cette hausse des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
alors en ce qui concerne le gaz ça c'est
un autre problème et là c'est
typiquement un problème de politique
européenne de réglementation européenne
au départ on avait ce qu'on appelait des
contrats à long terme alors ses contrats
long terme effectivement quand les prix
baisser vers sa vie etc ont payé un
petit peu plus cher que ce qu'on aurait
dû payer mais quand les prix montent et
et bien payés nettement moins cher et
puis bah voilà v les technocrates de
bruxelles on dit mais c'est pas du tout
logique d'abord un un contrat de long
terme eh bien ça vous bloque avec un
contractant dons dans le cadre de la
france et de l'europe c'était soit la
russie soit l'algérie et puis justement
ça empêche de faire des économies encore
faut-il que les prix ne remontent pas
donc on a démantelé le système des
contrats de long terme on est passé à un
régime ou en fait le prix du gaz est
fixé sur des marchés journalier bon
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait les
marchés spot et ça aboutit à quoi ça
aboutit à ce que le prix du gaz sont en
fait indexé sur le prix du pétrole alors
qu'il ne l'était pas il ya quinze ans où
il y avait un temps est donc le résultat
c'est que aujourd'hui ma comme les prix
du pétrole remontent et bien évidemment
le prix du gaz remontent massivement et
là c'est quand même extrêmement
important parce que le gaz passe et
c'est ce qu'on utilise pour se chauffer
c'est ce qu'on utilise pour faire la
cuisine et sa touche quand même un
nombre de gens tout à fait considérable
1 pour l'électricité alors pour
l'électricité il ya encore un autre
problème quand on regarde par exemple
techniquement d'ouvrir l'électricité
française c'est du nucléaire s'est très
largement du nucléaire et donc comme les
centrales sont amorties depuis longtemps
puisque maintenant le les centrales
elles ont entre 30 et pratiquement 50
ans un pour les pour les plus vielles
devrait payer
des sommes extrêmement faible sauf que
l'union européenne là encore est
intervenue et a dit on veut faire un
grand marché de l'électricité on veut
des monopolisé et privatiser les
systèmes électriques or pour faire un
grand marché il faut faire un prix si
vous voulez vous ne pouvez pas faire de
marché si dans chaque pays vous avez des
prix différents donc on a voulu faire un
prix unique à marché unique prix unique
et sur quoi on a indexé le prix
d'électricité je vous le donne en mille
sur le prix du gaz un résultat
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le consommateur français
alors c'est pas vrai pour des pays par
exemple comme l'allemagne qui ont
abandonné le nucléaire et qui donc sont
très dépendants ou du gaz ou du charbon
mais le consommateur français qui
auraient dû être protégé sans cette
politique européenne eh bien ils surent
paye son électricité à cause de cela il
ya également les taxes oui tout à fait
ah ça vous avez tout à fait raison la
part des taxes dans les prix des
carburants elle est tout à fait énorme
c'est d'ailleurs une tradition assez
français n'est pas que il ya d'autres
pays où vous avez aussi des détaxes très
importante et là on voit là il ya même
quelque chose qui est je dirais un petit
peu aberrant qui moi me me hérisse par
rapport à ce que je sais ce que j'avais
appris dans mes études il voulait de
droit fiscal vous payer une taxe sur la
taxe c'est à dire que vous avez sur la
tcp eux qui l attaquent ce principal sur
les carburants va vous avez une tv là
sur la tpe
résultat quand vous payez votre gazole
pour des gens qui par exemple en 2010
elle ou même chose si vous payez de
l'essence sans plomb à 0,95 et bien le
prix du carburant avec le raffinage
c'est pas le prix brut
c'est 30% du prix à la pompe donc on
voit qu'il y a là des marges extrêmement
importante et on comprend pourquoi il ya
beaucoup alors que ce soit des candidats
où que ce soit même des gens de la
majorité qui s'adresse au gouvernement
et qui disent c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
jouer de manière à faire baisser le coût
pour le consommateur n'a manifestement
ce n'est pas l'option en tout cas qui a
été choisie on en a parlé à
jacques pourquoi vous parlez de
l'hypocrisie alors c'est quand même si
vous voulez une énorme hypocrisie parce
que on voit bien que la dynamique
actuelle des prix de tous les carburants
alors que ce soit le pétrole va que ce
soit les sens que ce soit le gard où que
ce soit l'électricité tout ça c'est de
l'énergie globalement que tous ces prix
sont aujourd'hui dominé par une
dynamique qui est la dynamique de
privatisation et de déréglementation
qu'a voulu impulser l'union européenne
au nom justement de la construction d'un
grand marché unique de l'énergie et que
les gouvernements français c'est pas que
la faute à bruxelles à il faut être
honnête à dieu que les gouvernements
français se sont précipités pour faire
appliquer on a privatisé gaz de france
on a privatisé une partie de dr bref
aujourd'hui vous avez des politiques qui
lève les bras au ciel et qui disent ah
oui c'est impossible les français payent
leur énergie trop cher certains
problèmes mais il fallait y penser plus
tôt il fallait y penser plus tôt parce
que nous sommes dassé nombre
d'économistes qui avons dit cette
logique de privatisation
cette logique de déréglementation elle a
été mise en place aux états unis en
californie il ya vingt ans de cela hees
avait abouti à des hausses massives du
prix de l'énergie on savait que c'était
ça qu'il y avait dans les cartons avec
cette déréglementation et 7
démonopolisation peut dire du marché
alors bien sûr maintenant on va penser à
des mesures que ce soit le chèque
énergie ou qu'on appelle autrement que
ce soit déblocage de prêts d'un ces
blocages de prix on comprend bien que
sauf à changer la réglementation battent
ils ne pourront durer que six mois
maintenant pas plus vouloir en 2022
le premier ministre a fait voir d'après
ce que j'ai entendu il n'a pas exclu que
cilaos continuer à ce rythme sur 2022 eh
bien on regarderait du côté de la
structure fiscale c'est-à-dire du poids
des taxes sur les carburants mais tout
cela j'utilise une expression populaire
c'est cautère sur jambe de bois ce n'est
qu'un palliatif en fête est donc là il y
a une vraie hypocrisie des politiques
qui consiste à ne pas choisir de
politique énergétique claire ne pas s'y
tenir et après évidemment d'en déplorer
les effets bref je vais pas faire mon
bossuet mais vous savez ces gens qui se
lamentent sur des faits dont ils
chérissent les causes eh bien nous
sommes exactement dans cette situation
sur les prix d'énergie merci jacques
sapir et on rappelle les deux
principales annonces de premier ministre
ce soir le blocage les prix du gaz sur
toute l'année 2022 également une
indemnité impression de 100 euros qui
sera versée aux français de manière
automatique un qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros net par mois